so are you curious about what goes on
behind the scenes of the Mandalorian
well not only is there a major lack of
green screen everything you see on
screen is exactly what the actors were
looking at on set with the help of some
incredibly Innovative technology they
can create beautiful sets and Landscapes
with the click of a button obviously
actors need to be as convincing as
possible when recording ADR that's
automated dialogue replacement after the
scene has already been filmed you all
know Pedro Pascal is a very serious
actor so he needed his grogu prop in
hand to recreate the scene
the prop in question was actually a
pillow and can you imagine walking in on
Pedro Pascal reciting lines and
clutching a pillow in the sound booth
without context
so deciding on who would train grogu
like the real grogu not the pillow was
actually a difficult decision they threw
around the idea of bringing Ahsoka into
the show but ultimately decided she
wouldn't be a great fit for the role
after deciding on Luke the real
challenge began CGI they brought in Mark
Hamill as well as a 30 year old looking
body double and eventually Blended the
two together in a visual effects program
called Lola until they actually achieved
the Luke Skywalker we saw on screen so
what did you think about them bringing
in a CGI Skywalker or rather the lack of
green screens they were really trying to
avoid using green screens in the show so
they did some creative workarounds in
the end instead of having a green screen
they had to move around in light which
took forever those frustrations led to
some brilliant innovations that led to
the U of A green a green stage you have
pre-lit green areas that you could
expose that led to Green video walls
which is basically just putting green
behind the actor and using interactive
light to expose it the physical set
design in the middle of all of that also
had to match what was being displayed
which of course was built by the art
Department then there were the 3D models
plopped onto the LED environment that
surrounded the set which can respond to
camera movement and emulate the real
world like how absolutely insane is that
but let's get deeper into that whole
video wall concept it's majorly
Innovative and one of the groundbreaking
technical aspects that the mandalorians
set the stage with we can have game
engine real-time render and video wall
technology coming together to create a
backdrop there are literally seven
machines pumping out visuals and this is
just for the pre-production imagine the
entire set surrounded with the simplest
way to put it huge LED TV screens and
you really quickly forget that you're
indoors and you're not out on some
Planet surface it actually feels like a
real three-dimensional environment
surrounding you I mean Tech basically
that's exactly what it is so like does
anyone know where I can get one of these
to transform my apartment let me know in
the comments
so not only is the set completely real
in a visual aspect they're able to
capture every single shot on camera
without having to take it into post you
end up with real-time final pixels in
camera they can even do stuff like
change the positions of mountains from
one end of the stage to the other and
considering I can barely manage to turn
my phone camera off at night mode
consider me impressed you could switch
between
Iceland location to the desert location
all within the same day of shooting they
can do pretty much anything in real time
change the time of day the location on
the sun you name it so typically shots
of a character in a vehicle traveling at
high speeds through a complex
environment were one of the most
difficult things to achieve they figured
a way around this was led screens taking
this technique of image-based lighting
that we've been using in computer
Graphics they're taking a common form
technique and like switching it up
they're using it to light a subject
instead of a still image still with me
then they jump in with texture mapping
so the camera can move anywhere we would
do Interiors like we're in a herzog's
office and this technique
allowed them to capture whatever they
want in any environment from any angle
at any speed and another way this works
out better than using green screens was
because of the reflection on Mando's
costume and no matter what there was
always going to be reflection of the
environment from his helmet think about
if they used green screens the only
thing that would be reflected is the
color green so not the vibe we were
getting exactly what we wanted to out of
his helmet so everything that they do on
this set is to save time and most
importantly money and one of the secret
tricks involved is called a French
reverse where you hit a button and the
world rotates 180 degrees it just speeds
up the whole shooting process this whole
thing takes just seconds not only that
but everything they do is saved so if
they decide they don't really like the
way that it looks they can easily just
hit a button and go back to the way it
was a few seconds ago or even the day
before everything they do is completely
backed up so they have free reign to
experiment with anything they want it
really is inspiring because there it is
what you see is what you're getting the
only thing they really had to mess with
was the color correction particularly
when it came to the Practical set
whether it be a rock or a barrel or
something I would try to color correct
it to match what was on the set so if
they switched up the scene there could
be a blue sky that reflects a ton of
blue onto the rock essentially changing
its entire look so they had to be very
detail-oriented when it came to nailing
down those colors
all right but we must protect Pedro
Pascal at all costs which is why he had
not won but two stunt doubles Latif
Crowder stepped up for all the
hand-to-hand combat and Brendan Wayne
packed the big guns this was mostly due
to the fact that Brandon's a
professional shooter so they wanted to
utilize his skills on screen though of
course Pedro Pascal was the one behind
Mando's mask most of the time but when
it came to those intense combat and
shooting scenes his stunt doubles were
happy to take the reins it actually
brings up my skill set as well you know
if he's humbled with a lot of energy and
heart I have to really be on point and
like speaking of doubles did you know
that there were quite a few alternate
designs for our favorite baby Yoda a lot
of them were actually rejected for being
too cute and like who knew that could
even be a possibility others were
rejected for being too ugly ouch or
because they had the wrong proportions
like look at this guy all of those Yoda
variations led to the Yoda we know and
love today I want fans to feel like
they're having that experience right
there in front of them so what do you
think did they ultimately pick the best
design
was done talking about Yoda well I'm not
did you know that he had to be operated
by not one not two not even three but
four puppeteers it comes forward tilt
the head up a little bit yeah now reach
it seriously takes a village one
controlled the eyes one controlled the
head and body while a third controlled
the face and a fourth controlled the
body and arms movement Werner even
demanded that they used the puppet in
all the scenes instead of rendering in
digital versions of it they filmed it
one-on-one it was heartbreakingly
beautiful I mean it makes sense like if
you spent all those resources creating
the puppet and dedicating an entire team
to operating its movements why wouldn't
you want to just use it as much as you
could
so what do you think are you even more
impressed with the Mandalorian after
finding out that the sets were created
in real time often in seconds baby Yoda
is like so well loved that he has four
handlers giving him screen time Pedro
Pascal takes his acting to a whole
nother level with his security blanket
pillow prop what's your favorite behind
the scenes fact